[Música]
primeiramente eu gostaria de contar uma
história
na verdade uma entre três histórias de
tempestade
a minha fala é sobre três histórias de
tempestade e uma oficina de na atividade
a história começa a se a chuva havia
devastado tudo nas ruas todas pela
meadas vazias
dezenas de casas vieram abaixo um
desastre
famílias inteiras desapareceram sob a
terra escura e fétida o homem de
uniforme
atônito não reconhecia aquele cheiro não
era o cheiro de todas as outras terras
que já vira desabar ano após ano cheio
lancinante incômodo do suportável
o alento oferecido poucos dias após as
chuvas veio da mesma forma como um forte
vento como uma tempestade que decretou a
necessidade de não mais chorar sobre os
escombros daquilo que já estava perdido
e encerrado
nem procurar culpados jornais as notas
oficiais da prefeitura os posts da
internet diziam é preciso unir a todos
em um mesmo olhar para frente que
vislumbrasse um futuro de reconstrução
da cidade
assim de passo em passo degrau em degrau
as coisas voltariam a ser como eram
voltaria a entrar no trilho eixos
no room como no qual cabem as comoventes
e reconfortantes imagens das ações
sociais voltadas ao cuidado emergencial
das massas de desabrigados mas não cabe
o gesto repentino do idoso que expulsa
câmera e recusa ter seu atendimento
médico no pátio de uma escola
transformado em um espetáculo e lição de
superação pessoal rumo no qual cabem os
novos planos de contenção das encostas
desenvolvidos pela equipe de
especialistas em terrenos estruturas e
cidades mas não cabem os urros da
família que tumultua ordem do
reconhecimento dos corpos em
decomposição
chamem os psicólogos para conter os
ânimos desesperados dizem os homens de
terno gestores da cidade como no qual
cabe a voz firme de dicção corretas sem
interrupções da repórter que relata a
seqüência de evento que marcaram esta
que marcaram a tragédia mas não cabe o
gajo o silêncio irritado do rapaz
ao ser indagado sobre como pretendia
voltar à sua vida normal como no qual
cabem as lágrimas dos pobres coitados
vítimas dos desastres mártires das
injustiças sociais
mas não cabe a fúria da mulher que veste
fraldas para não cessar diz cavar a
terra com as mãos na esperança de chegar
ao tempo de um último fôlego
o que cabe nos nossos modos de contar as
nossas histórias
o que cabe nas formas que contamos as
histórias dessa cidade das nossas
cidades de alguma cidade do que quer que
seja cidade
esta história que eu ia pra vocês é
parte do meu trabalho de tese onde eu
conto o episódio conhecido talvez por
alguns de vocês chamado à guerra do
mundo a queda do morro do bumba
acontecido na cidade de niterói em abril
de 2010 um bairro que foi construído
sobre um lixão desativado e que durante
a sua queda evidenciou lixos lixo de
outros tempos
o chorume e histórias que ali foram
interrompidas e cantar aquele momento
era uma lama fétida esses acontecimentos
de ordem que parecem naturais mas assim
como outros acontecimentos que acontecem
nas nossas cidades sejam os movimentos
de greve sejam as perseguições aos
trabalhadores e às suas mortes sejam as
lamas tóxicas de algumas cidades que
acabaram simplesmente submersas
todas esses fatos que talvez não sejam
catástrofes naturais mas que percebam
muitas vezes ganham um tom de natural ou
ganha uma certa naturalidade como se
fossem tempestades que passam e nada
temos a ver cada uma dessas catástrofes
episódios acontecimentos nos fazem
contar e recontar histórias das nossas
vidas das nossas cidades e contando
essas histórias nos deparamos muitas
vezes com esses contar e recontar es que
vão aparecendo que vão fazendo aparecer
alguns trechos da cidade que parecem que
são menos cidade alguns modos de contar
e recontar essas histórias vão fazendo
aparecer que algumas cores da pele
humana são menos humana
e algumas gentes são menos gente e daí a
gente insiste na pergunta o que é que
cabe nos nossos modos de contar a
história das nossas experiências das
nossas cidades da nossa vida do nosso
país o que não cabe daí atentos a essa
indagação muitas vezes rapidamente
tentamos respondê-las trazendo
depoimentos das vidas pessoais de como
as pessoas conseguiram vencer tantas
adversidades em meio à catástrofe estão
severas e violentas e acompanhamos nos
jornais na televisão muitas vezes aquela
câmera que faz um na lágrima no rosto da
pessoa que revela lhe como conseguiu
arrancar à força de si para vencer essas
adversidades mas reparem que histórias
seriam essas cidades seriam essas
quando nós contamos a partir dessas
personalidades dessas vidas individuais
seriam história de homens fortes de
cidades feitas por pessoas bravas
insistentes
certa feita eu fui convidada para
participar de um evento que falava sobre
a catástrofe que assolou a região
serrana fluminense e na véspera do
evento eu soube com mais detalhes que o
nome da mesa à qual ea coordenaria
'media' eu sou psicóloga talvez não por
acaso se chamava narrativas de superação
muitas pessoas foram à mesa interessadas
na discussão sobre as narrativas de
superação talvez por que lembrasse
aquilo que aconteceu talvez porque esse
tema de alguma maneira instigue nos faça
pensar força que nem imaginávamos ter no
entanto esse modo de abordar esse modo
de contar histórias é absolutamente
perigoso também perigoso porque de um
lado ele ignora ou não quer saber do
estatuto desse acontecimento dessa
tragédia ela natural ela naturalizada e
mesmo os encaminhamentos dessa tragédia
o que se fez e conjuntos habitacionais
que ruíram antes mesmo de foram
entregues mas sobretudo o perigo de
contar histórias a partir dessas
narrativas de superação pessoal ele se
encontra na medida em que menos preza
aquilo que chamamos da potência do
impessoal disse que nos através dessas
histórias que nos narram os testes em
que os compõem
dessas tramas que nos trazem algo que
não é meu não sou eu mas me compõem e
constitui essas narrativas
elas são absolutamente perigosas porque
elas não dão lugar ao estatuto da
memória na sua condição política no
quanto ela pode ser contada e recontada
e reinventada disputada gaguejada
remontada
é uma memória que não se enganem ela não
tem amor a um passado tal como ele foi
uma busca dos fatos mais verdadeiros mas
é uma memória que tem uma atenção
absoluta ao tempo de agora aquilo que
vivemos agora aquilo que é o nosso tempo
as nossas urgências aos perigos que
vivemos
aquilo que estamos nos tornando
ultimamente temos nos tornado pessoas
muitos muito estranhos
os fascismos os binarismo as destinações
de ódio
essa memória talvez a propósito das suas
próprias hesitações
a propósito dos seus próprios gaguejo
porque feita e refeita insistentemente
ela talvez interrompa uma outra
tempestade
existe um quadro de clay intitulado
angelus novus nele está representado um
anjo que parece estar a ponto de afastar
se de algo em que crava o seu olhar em
seus olhos estão arregalados sua boca
está aberta e as asas estão estirados o
anjo da história tem de parecer assim
ele tem seu rosto voltado para o passado
onde uma cadeia de eventos parece diante
de nós
ele enxerga uma única catástrofe que sem
cessar a montou escombros sobre
escombros e os arremessa a seus pés
ele bem que gostaria de morar se de
despertar os mortos e juntar os
destroços mas do paraíso só para uma
tempestade que se emaranhou em suas asas
e é tão forte que o anjo não pode mais
fechar mas essa tempestade
o império irresistivelmente para o
futuro para o qual das costas enquanto
um amontoado de escombros diante dele
cresce até o céu o que nós chamamos de
progresso é essa tempestade
então eu vou me apresentar eu chamo ana
eu sou psicóloga e professora da
universidade federal fluminense e eu
pesquiso esses cacos
esses restos eu me interesso por esses
destroços
por isso que é rebootar alho restolho
dessa história que parece segue por si
só uma história linear que se apresenta
no seu futuro
lá na frente onde somos levados parece
que independente da nossa vontade
eu recolhi ou pesquisa o trabalho esses
destroços de um cotidiano urbano de uma
narrativa de uma cidade que parece tem
que seguir sempre em frente
esses destroços esses restos me
interessam não é na medida em que lhes
apresente a verdadeira
o face a verdadeira versão da história
não há neles qualquer é grandioso idade
moral que nos faz olhar para eles com
comparecimento ou esperando neles uma
maior autenticidade seu interesse por
esses fragmentos por esses destroços por
esses restos é porque eles colocam em
xeque essa linearidade e essa força que
impede tudo pra frente
não é porque por eles podemos fazer uma
analogia a diferença mas porque ele nos
exige uma atenção às violências que são
feitas cotidianamente para sustentar
essas versões oficiais e lineares da
história
esses restos eles são absolutamente
fundamentais e pertinentes na medida em
que eles fazem observar estar atentos
aos discursos que se querem contínuos e
oficiais de entonação firme segura sem
gaguejo que diz volta redonda na cidade
do aço
a cidade do progresso de homens
comprometidos com o crescimento da nação
outras narrativas talvez mais curtas mas
com o mesmo empenho e vontade de
totalidade que diz
brasil um país de ordem e progresso
quantas violência são necessárias
diariamente para sustentar essa fala tão
segura e contínuo o que podem essas
histórias
elas podem talvez não fazer um elogio a
uma certa estilística do gaguejo mas
elas podem fazer que essas histórias
contínuas tão cheias disse que não se
permitem as hesitações que elas possam
em algum momento gaguejar abrir frestas
brechas
esses restos eles tencionam com esse
nosso desejo de totalidade e porque não
de totalitarismo
elas nos lembram que essas histórias
oficiais elas também são inventadas
elas também estão disputas
também são criadas elas são políticas
esses restos eles nos lembram que o
tempo não consegue por si só não é
autônomo
ele não tem um caminho dado de uma
maneira independente das nossas práticas
das nossas políticas e que o tempo não
segue de ideia ideia mas talvez de
combate em combate
mas se esse tempo linear do progresso
dessa idéia de que segue sempre fez nos
parece absolutamente óbvio difícil de
problematiza difícil de contestar a
gente pergunta mas como poderia ser
diferente o que é possível
o que eu trago aqui não é simplesmente
uma ideia para iluminar a mente de todos
nós aqui não se trata disso
se essa ideia de um tempo linear da
problematização desse tempo linear segue
sempre em frente
josé absolutamente é natural as nossas
sensibilidade é porque justamente esses
nossos modos de narrar a experiência a
história a cidade constitui a nossa
experiência nossa vivência nossa
corporeidade nas condições mais
capilares mais minuciosos
é por isso que aqui não se trata
simplesmente de apresentar uma ideia mas
contar pra vocês que a gente se propõe é
antes de tudo um exercício ético um
exercício de reinvenção de si e do outro
nessa dimensão da política de políticas
de austeridade e por isso nesse momento
a gente tem inventado criado um projeto
conjunto com a biblioteca municipal aqui
em volta redonda onde ela se organiza
como oficina de natividade onde o nosso
trabalho é fazer justamente esse
exercício de reinvenção de um corpo
disponível as narrativas
a proposição de uma experimentação de
outras temporário idades na própria
oficina no próprio espaço de contar e
ouvir histórias e se assim fazemos é
também porque apostamos nos espaços
públicos com
os passos de disputa pelo próprio
sentido de público está tão e cristão
jogo e o espaço público da biblioteca
aí sim construído ele próprio como um
território de passagem dessas histórias
histórias que antes mesmo de poderem se
dizer antes mesmo de anunciar um
possível são esmagadas aniquilada as
silenciosas nossa oficina se propõe a
construir inventar corpos disponíveis
essas histórias mil mudas disponíveis a
narração e a terceira história de
tempestade
é essa aqui é esse evento é um evento
que não está se escrevendo uma história
que não passa escrevendo simplesmente
pela minha fala mas por vários
acontecimentos que aqui se entrelaçam
por várias expectativas do que se espera
que se fale sobre esse palco do que se
ouve o que se quer que se diga a
felicidade não falou de política
o que é preciso para construir esse
momento do acontecimento e aí muitos de
nós esperamos sair com idéias incríveis
revolucionários que nos motivam mas
talvez vocês me perdoe
talvez muitas vezes estejamos aqui
esperando na verdade que nossos
espíritos sedentos de algum sentido
nesse mesmo tempo que em volta tudo pra
frente seja saciado
talvez estejamos esperando que de alguma
maneira em alguma medida essas idéias
acalentem essa experiência desse tempo
homogêneo vazio que engolfa a tristeza a
felicidade e absolutamente tudo e nos
deixar nas desviados e nos faz querer
nos remediar seja com pílulas o convite
na internet
a tempestade que se narra é aquela que
nos implica o quanto nós perpetuamos
esta tempestade preenchendo os gaguejo
da história com sentidos narrativas e
doutorados e mantemos tudo
do jeito como sempre fui obrigada
[Aplausos]